now to Iran where the government's
violent Crackdown on peaceful protest is
now in its 18th day one Human Rights
group says at least 133 people have been
killed so far hundreds have been
arrested mostly young people since the
death of a 22 year old woman in the
custody of the country's morality police
as Roxanna siberi shows us its Iranian
woman who are front and center of the
protest
[Applause]
unprecedented scenes in the Islamic
Republic of Iran schoolgirls across the
country clouding the law some uncovering
their hair many even chanting death to
the dictator
that's all for Freedom are also
spreading across universities
everyone is out on the streets this
college student said in a video message
on condition of anonymity we have to
keep going they can't arrest all of us
young people under the age of 25 appear
to be fueling the protests despite the
regime's harsh Crackdown
on Sunday Security Forces besieged
tehran's Elite Sharif University where
students have been protesting peacefully
the Student Union said armed plane close
agents Chase students down in a parking
lot and brutally arrested several of
them eyewitnesses said the ground was
covered in blood they think that by
using Force the brutal force they can be
in power forever but of course they're
wrong mazir bihari is the london-based
editor of Iran wire news and a former
political prisoner in Iran
so how is this Young Generation
different from previous young
Generations in Iran my generation and
the generation after me we gave the
governments the chance to reform itself
what this generation can see that this
government the Islamic Republic cannot
be reformed so this government has to be
ended Islamic Republic has been around
for 43 years and many young Iranians are
fed up with the global isolation and
severe sanctions imposed on their
country
our problem is not with Islam or
religion we just want people to live as
they like Iran and not be jailed for it
please hear our voices she adds help us
in any way you can
[Applause]
Tony as you know I am half Iranian and I
lived and reported in Iran for several
years these days many Iranians are
reaching out saying it's very important
for the international news media to keep
the protests and the regime's response
in the spotlight
and we'll keep following it I know you
will as well Roxanna severian London for
us Roxanna thank you very much